you
[Music]
for me I even though it like I'm a
borderline psychopath a near psychopath
in a pro-social psychopath in a way I'm
a lucky psychopath in the sense that I
grew up with in such a wonderful family
in the family my interactions with my
mother and father my aunt and uncle's my
grandparents everybody around me they
knew that something is wrong and and
they treated me really unbelievably so I
had this wonderful but but with this
this wonderful upbringing my mother and
a couple of her sisters they I think
they had a good instincts about this and
they kept me away from things and when I
had gone through a very kind of a dark
period in in when I was going through
puberty and she needs something's really
wrong and I think she talked to some of
the teachers and made sure that it was
very busy so every day I was in you know
I was in five
Walter high school in college and all
sorts of very active contact sports and
I was involved in the drama club and in
the band and I played instrument and it
was like always doing something and I
think that that probably she knew that
for a kid that's a good thing I was
always successful I always knew what I
want to be always did well at school so
I never needed money I never needed
power and I just thought to myself well
what if I did what if I did what if I
wasn't so lucky in all these ways and I
don't feel any guilt about being lucky
you know I'm happy it happened but but I
was just thinking and you know I could
have turned out much differently but I
think and that's so bad because I think
I was treated so well that trigger
wasn't pull down the genes you know
they're a couple of genes that I do have
it was a serotonin transporter that if
you're early in life if you're brought
into an abusive or an abandonment
situation it's very bad for your
ultimate development but if you you have
that same allele the serotonin
transporter with and you shown a lot of
love it has the opposite effect it kind
of negates the other negative things so
this is amazing so it really made sense
and it really is like a biological
hardcore reason to be good to your kids
your families kids set a neighborhood
kids because if you just say it it
sounds like happy talk great now we hate
war be nicely but there's real
biological reasons for it I think it's
very compelling and that has been
exciting because I'm for me it's
exciting because it's scientifically
interesting it it opens up something
about the universe and that's what
drives me it really does and if it
didn't it would it wouldn't but on the
side I knew that I was really lucky to
you